bonsoir le parc du pilat et là des plus
petits parcs naturels régionaux ce qui
représente l'énorme avantage pour les
aventuriers et c'est d'eux que l'on va
parler aujourd'hui de pouvoir le
parcourir en deux trois jours maximum et
en deux trois jours maximum vous allez
en faire vous allez en voir des choses à
pied avait été petits détails pratiques
mêmes chaussures de rando couteau suisse
et celle de survie indispensable
donc de restaurer le moyenne montagne
plan diantre
en fait de m
et al un écrin vert situé à trois quarts
d'heure genieau
d'entrée du parc du pilat c'est qu'on
est un belvédère fantastique sur
quasiment un quart du territoire de la
france donc ça c'est vraiment la chose
qui frappe quand on est dans le pilat
c'est qu'on se retrouve très rapidement
dans des situations de balcon au-dessus
de la vallée du rhône au dessus des
alpes en demeurant en ayant des
perspectives sur le volet ou sur les ou
sur les volcans d'auvergne qui sont
assez extraordinaire malleval sa base se
fit numéro trois sur le physique du
pilat premier tronçon du parcours de
trois jours que les avons imaginé pour
orienter le groupe de randonneurs pascal
écoguide au parc ça vient vite favorites
ici on se perd pas on s'égare tout au
plus
donc voilà les premières bornes quand on
se repère sur le sur le sentier
d'interprétation station 20 donc on vous
parle désormais des douleurs
on nous parle du gnr vous par des
parrains derrière au programme de la
matinée cinq heures de marche dénivelé
900 m parfait pour une mise en jambes
vont être non mais là encore pas vu il
faut être en super condition physique
pour faire des des randos comme ça de
plusieurs jours dans le pilat il vaut
mieux toute façon ce soir dans tous les
cas c'est vrai que bon quand même pas
c'est quand même pas les alpes il ya
quand même des petits morceaux qu'on ne
pouvait le voir là l'accès à saint-sabin
ou bon surtout lorsqu on l'emmène le
pique nique
on est quand même assez chargé donc
qu'en minimes et en vtt là c'est encore
pire
roman un mâle wallon repérera des cactus
sans saba perché à 1000 mètres
d'altitude laine polaire indispensable
le pilat étudièrent de contrastes
paysager climatique sur le chemin des
airelles des myrtilles à profusion une
comme des saillies des tonnes de
cailloux qui rendent le pas du
randonneur hésitant l'ascension
chaotique
on m'a fait le plus difficile mais
maintenant on va arriver sur les crêtes
qui je crois en france par pas loin de
l'arrivée notre anglais ne tient
toujours
juste après avoir traversé le forez des
fils hier le casse croûte et le petit
remontant indispensable avant de
repartir
nous ne savons si cette étape au matin
les jambes étaient raides et cela n'est
pas aller en s'arrangeant avec les 30 km
de vtt
il faut bien compter bon ils ont quatre
heures pour les plus rapides et puis 6
heures pour les autres attendent on est
parti pour la journée sans problème
nos riverains aujourd'hui le lendemain
le groupe est reparti sur l'autre
versant de la montagne mais à cheval
cette voie